هذا وتكتسي التطورات والحدوديه البولنديه
البيلاروسيه اهميتها الاستراتيجيه من
كونها المنطقه الفاصله بين دول الناتو
والمجال الحيوي لروسيا ولحلفائها وتشترك
بولندا مع بيلاروسيا في حدود تمتد لمسافه
418 كيلومترا بدات بولندا بارسال عشره
الاف جندي من جيشها لتعزيز قوه حرس الحدود
في هذه المنطقه
سيدعم اربعه الاف منهم حرس الحدود بشكل
مباشر بينما سيكون سته الاف جندي في
الاحتياط تنفذ هذه القوات المختصه او
مخصصه للعمل على الحدود مهام قتاليه تشمل
الطيران التكتيكي وكذلك مجال نظام الدفاع
الجوي للحلفاء في الناتو هذا هو اعلنت
قياده حرس الحدود البولندي ان
19,000 جندي على عبروا الحدود بصفه غير
قانونيا من بيلاروسيا الى بولندا
هذا العام ما يعني ارتفاعا لافتا مقارنه
بما سجل العام الماضي بحوالي 16 الف عابر
بصفه غير قانونيه